[Music]
hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV today
my guest is salon comms
Glenn Greenwald the author of several
best-selling books including how would a
patriot act and a tragic legacy Glenn
has also just authored a Cato Institute
policy study on drug decriminalization
and Portugal and the lessons that we can
take from this in virtually completely
successful experiment let's talk about
drug decriminalization in Portugal your
paper is lessons for creating fair and
successful policies first tell us what
is the difference in Portugal between
decriminalization and legalization
well the difference in in general is is
the idea that legalization means that
there are no longer any legal
prohibitions of any kind on drug
consumption usage or possession whereas
in a decriminalize framework the law
continues to prohibit drug usage but
it's completely removed from the
criminal sphere so that if you violate
that prohibition or do the activity that
the law says you cannot do you're no
longer committing a crime you cannot be
turned into a criminal by the state
instead it's deemed to be an
administrative offence only and you're
put into an administrative proceeding
rather than a criminal proceeding
explained very quickly what what
happened in Portugal well what's
interesting is the impetus behind
decriminalization which took place in
2001 was not that there was some drive
to have a sort of libertarian ideology
perfected based on the idea that adults
should be able to use whatever
substances they want nor was it because
there's some adil ik upper middle class
setting I mean it looks Portugal was a
very poor country it's not Luxembourg or
Monaco or something like that and in
fact in the 1990s they had a spiraling
out of control drug problem addiction
was skyrocketing drug related
pathologies were increasing rapidly and
they were sort of taking this step out
of desperation and they convened a
Council of a political policy experts
and gave them the mandate to determine
which the which optimal policy approach
would enable them to best deal with
these these drug problems and the
council convened and studied all the
various options and decriminalization
was the answer to the question how can
we best
limit drug usage and drug addiction and
it was a policy designed to do that and
one of the things that you find is that
in fact decriminalization which removes
a certain amount of sanction from drug
use it actually correlates with less
drug use absolutely and you can look at
the empirical evidence which is quite
compelling and unambiguous in many
senses and in in a lot of demographic
groups especially the key demographic
groups in Portugal 15 to 19 years old
for instance from 2001 when
decriminalization was institutionalized
until say 2007 there has been a decrease
in absolute terms in the prevalence
rates of drug usages what explains that
because I mean a kind of basic theory
would say if you make drugs less if you
lower the cost of doing drugs by making
a less criminally offensive you would
have more of it well there's several
aspects one is the concern that
policymakers had the frustration in the
1990s when they were criminalizing is
the more they criminalized the more the
usage rates went up and one of the
reasons was was because when you tell
the population that you will imprison
them or treat them as criminals if they
identify themselves as drug users or you
learned that they're using drugs what
you do is you create a barrier between
the government and the citizenry such
that their citizenry fears the
government which means that government
officials can't offer treatment programs
they can't communicate with the
population effectively they can't offer
them services and so there was this
barrier that drug officials had and
couldn't overcome and criminalization
was in place but more importantly when
you spend all your money on arresting
and prosecuting and imprisoning people
for drug usage it means there's no money
for things like funding treatment or
educational campaigns or harm reduction
programs and once Portugal decriminalize
a huge amount of money that had gone to
putting its citizens into cages was
freed up and it enabled the government
to provide meaningful treatment to
people who wanted it and so addicts were
able to turn into non drug users and
usage rates went down what is the what's
the relevance for the United States we
have a incredibly vexed history with
drug policy we also have much higher
than average drug usage rates we have
more people in prison because of drugs
etc well I mean the I think the the
relevance is obvious which is we have
debates all the time now about things
like drug policy reform and
criminalisation and it's based purely in
speculation and fear-mongering of all
the horrible things that are supposedly
going to happen if we loosen our drug
laws and we can remove ourselves from
the realm of the speculative by looking
at Portugal which actually
decriminalized seven years ago in full
every drug and see that none of those
parade of Horrible's that's constantly
warned of by decriminalization opponents
actually came to fruition Lisbon didn't
turn into a drug haven for drug tourists
the explosive explosion and drug usage
rates that was predicted never
materialized in fact the opposite
happened and interestingly the populace
was split before decriminalization as to
whether it was a good idea eight years
ago and whereas now there's a virtual
consensus across the political spectrum
in Portugal that decriminalization has
acceded and there's no movement to
return to the criminalized framework
let's switch gears a little bit at salon
as well as in your book you write a lot
about civil liberties you were an
unsparing critic of George W Bush for
all totally understandable reasons on
civil liberties how is Obama shaping up
on civil liberties not very good I think
that the some of the signs are still
inconclusive for example there was a
flurry of symbolic executive orders in
the first week designed to placate civil
libertarians excluding yourself
including myself but it didn't it worked
for about a day or so um although it was
clear from the beginning that most of
the difficult questions were put off so
if you close Guantanamo in a year that's
a marginally good thing but then if you
if you retain the right or the claimed
right to detain people without due
process or worse you create perniciously
named national security courts that are
by design intended to constrict due
process and make it easier to detain
people without having to prove their
guilt and you move that into the United
States you actually transplant
Guantanamo from Cuba into United States
that actually could make things a lot
worse and they've retained a lot of
executive power theories that Bagram
detainees have no habeas corpus rights
that state secrets enable the President
to bar entire lawsuits even ones that
challenge his legal identities he's been
slow to release various torture memos
right yeah that's right in fact there
are three in particular that are
supposedly the most graphic detail and
graphic not in terms of intelligence
disclosures but in terms of authorizing
what are clearly were
crimes that are still concealed in the
EC Lu has continuously been battling
what is it what is guiding Obama I mean
I think all of us expected that Obama
would be better on civil liberties I'm
better on executive power than Bush have
been what is what is guiding his
decision-making on these types of issues
I mean one can only speculate of course
but I think that what is a principal
concern is that the more disclosures
there are about how extreme the
government's conduct was during the Bush
era the more the pressure will increase
both domestically and especially
internationally to actually do something
about it I mean if the evidence is
graphic and sufficiently vivid that our
government created it committed war
crimes brutal war crimes how do you
justify while paying lip service to the
rule of law the fact that your own
government successful government isn't
investigating or prosecuting and I think
they have a paralyzing political fear of
what will happen if they're forced into
investigating or prosecuting and so one
of the things they're trying to do is
use these secrecy instruments to keep
all of that behind the wall of secrecy
that the Bush administration operated by
Obama on drug policy during the campaign
he said he would end medical marijuana
raids on medical marijuana dispensaries
in states where they're legal Eric
Holder is AG said yes they were gonna do
that there have been a couple of raids
since then do you think Obama will be
good on drug policy or fair to middlin
well I mean again I think things are
quite preliminary but I thought it was
actually rather discouraging um one
could even say infuriating to watch him
respond to the question that people who
he invited online to submit questions
and vote on them it decided was the most
important one he sort of scoffed at the
question about drug legalization kind of
reacted like an adolescent would
giggling and snickering at the very
mention of marijuana and I don't think
anyone expected him to advocate
legalization but the idea that he
reinforced the notion that it was a
frivolous concern that the only people
interested would be people who want to
get high or otherwise freakish I thought
was a very discouraging sign and and as
you say the DEA in the last week rated a
perfectly legitimate medical marijuana
dispensary in San Francisco that had a
permit from the Health Department you
know going in with guns
and rating it and and it seemed to be a
violation of that policy as well so I
don't think the signs are very
encouraging initially well maybe we'll
meet again in Portugal though that'd be
great yeah we can take advantage of the
drug laws and do some field research
thank you very much our guest has been
Glenn Greenwald of salon.com who has
authored a Cato Institute public policy
paper on drug decriminalization and
Portugal thanks again for coming
[Music]